c'est sous liberté conditionnelle que
l'ancien jardinier est sortie et ce
matin revenons à présent sur ce qu'il
convient d'appeler l'affairé omar raddad
condamné à 18 ans de réclusion pour le
meurtre de ghislaine marchal en juin 91
un verdict qui avait suscité émotion et
doute le rappel des faits dominique
verdeilhan filmé par hasard dans une
prison du sud de la france
omar raddad depuis sept ans il clame son
innocence depuis quatre ans il souhaite
la révision de son procès enquête
dirigée instruction bâclée procès
controversé mais une simple inscription
en lettres de sang omar m'a tuer
condamne le jardinier marocain à 18 ans
réclusion criminelle pour la justice
la victime a désigné du bout des doigts
son assassin peu importe les
invraisemblances aucun indice matériel
relevé dans la villa de ghislaine
marchal à mougins ne vient confirmer
l'accusation
aucune empreinte des relevés 40
intellectuels prennent la défense d'omar
raddad
j'ai tout de suite vu peut-être aussi
comme romancier à quel point tout était
invraisemblable russie mais pourquoi est
ce que dans une instruction judiciaire
ont fait disparaître des preuves
pourquoi est-ce que à la demande de la
famille la justice accepte de d'assainir
et le corps de madame marchal le corps
de ghislaine marchal incinérés aucune
contre expertise n'était possible
les détectives eux continuent l'enquète
c'est d'abord l'apparition d'un second
omar au maroc un ex-détenu innocente le
jardinier marocain
hier c'est un privé qui affirmait
connaître les vrais coupables des pistes
soient fantaisiste 68 plus sérieuse
les conclusions d'un expert en écriture
sollicité par l'avocat de la défense
maître vergès pour lui
madame marchal n'est pas l'auteur de
l'inscription omar m'a tuer je n'ai pas
trouvé de forme significative de forme
typés qui caractérise en écrit
aussi bien danser dans ces lettres de
sang que dans les lettres de comparaison
morjane la certitude de l'expert
convaincra-t-elle la commission de
révision pour reconnaître ses erreurs la
justice exige des éléments nouveaux
ainsi l'affairé seznec la ferme hills et
thiennot ont été recalées en cinq ans
661 dossiers ont été présentés 15
seulement ont débouché sur une révision